[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de
france24 esta semana ponemos los focos
de nuevo en Perú un país vive una crisis
interminable dos meses después para ello
me acompañan tres invitados en este
estudio que ya les pasó a presentar
Valery robán Acevedo es profesora de
antropología social en la universidad
París y de bienvenida Buenos días Carlos
y yo mascar y periodista independiente
especializado en Latinoamérica
bienvenido Buenos días Carlos y lisel
Quirós historiador especialista en
América Latina de la universidad sergi
París bienvenido
Perú la crisis interminable en nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
Perú sigue sumido en una convulsión
social y política que no parece tener
salida las protestas se mantienen
después de casi dos meses de desde el
autogolpe fallido de Pedro castillo y
las decenas de muertos por la represión
policial la sensación en las calles Es
que la situación se ha vuelto
insostenible nadie piensa a estas
alturas en las elecciones como una
solución sino como el Mar el mar menor
El Congreso de Perú rechaza El noveno
proyecto del adelanto electoral y la
presidenta dinable asegura que no va a
renunciar al cargo El clamor para unas
elecciones anticipadas no es solo
nacional organismos internacionales como
la oea han pedido que la llamada las
urnas se haga cuanto antes repasemos
algunas portadas que nos deja la prensa
a diario La República recoge las
declaraciones de la propia boluarte no
voy a dimitir en medio de toda esta
situación New York Times se ha llevado a
su portada el llanto de una madre que ha
perdido a su hijo de 15 años en las
protestas el diario gestión trata otra
deriva como esta crisis está afectando
la economía del la crisis frena el
descenso del riesgo país del Perú bueno
dos meses después de que se iniciara
esta crisis parece que no hay salida por
lo que vemos una situación insostenible
a la que nadie sabe al menos Cómo poner
final valerino no sé si es la sensación
que tiene sí la preocupación es muy
grande porque ni El Ejecutivo ni el
legislativo están queriendo bueno dejar
el poder y dejar sus propios intereses
entonces las manifestaciones este están
siguiendo y la preocupación es que va a
pasar ahora o sea van a seguir
manifestando indudablemente y el temor
es que haya más muertos no entonces el
tema de la presión internacional creo
que es importante sin embargo no quizás
el hecho de La amenaza sobre las los
financiamientos que se yo pueda ser
también una manera de hacer que quizás
convoquen elecciones anticipadas no sé
no sé creen que no hay esta crisis o que
no hay voluntad para encontrarlas que
son cosas distintas y yo creo que no hay
voluntad O sea al menos ahora para
encontrar una salida pero una tiene que
tener una voluntad política desde ambos
partes de la de la sociedad peruana
tanto de la izquierda que de la derecha
hoy día si lo que se está jugando por el
legislativo es que cada uno cada cada
congresista quiere quiere guardar quiere
quedarse entonces podemos también hablar
de también que vamos quedando también
una crisis sino también las mentalidades
ya van evaluando a este nivel la
presidenta boluarte dice que todo está
en manos del Congreso y se niega a
renunciar al cargo otra de las salidas
que podría llevar a convocatoria
electoral lisel por qué están bloqueadas
estas salidas las salidas están
bloqueadas por lo que acaban de señalar
es decir que no hay una voluntad
política del de todos los que están hoy
en día en el poder ya sea de la derecha
como la izquierda de pasar a un proceso
de negociación y transformación de la
sociedad peruana porque fundamentalmente
el problema es un país dividido un país
una un país al que no se le han
reconocido derechos desde el nacimiento
de la República peruana desde entonces
eso es algo tan importante como cambios
que deben haber que se necesita una
verdadera voluntad una voluntad de
escuchar a los a los llamamientos de los
peruanos y peruanas que no viven en Lima
que están en diferentes regiones del
país y una voluntad de integrarlos
probablemente como el proceso
constitucional si como un ejemplo que se
da siempre no en comparación el de chile
por ejemplo integrar verdaderamente a
los pueblos originarios en las
discusiones a los grupos feministas a
todas y todos aquellos que hasta aquí No
han participado verdaderamente en una
constitución en la Constitución de un
verdadero organización social distinta a
la que hemos tenido hasta aquí la
decisión de un posible adelanto
electoral está en manos del congreso que
a una institución que es la peor
valorada del país con un 7% de la obra
de aprobación según las últimas
encuestas Claro si tiene tan poco
aprobación de donde tiene que partir la
decisión pues en menudas estamos no
valeri
desacreditada ya la institución de por
sí cómo se recupera Esa credibilidad
institucional está totalmente
desacreditada Pero eso tiene que ver
este ya en un mediado plazo Porque desde
el 90 en la época en que se llamaba la
década de la antipolítica como lo dijo
de gregory este estamos en un
debilitamiento de los partidos políticos
que más que todo hoy en día en el
congreso son como grupos de intereses
claro a veces incluso con interés
mafiosos este que pasan proyectos de
leyes por intereses privados y no para
el interés común y colectivo Entonces es
cierto que una reforma institucional
profunda es necesaria y esta
probablemente como lo decía lizel tenga
que pasar por el tema de un nuevo pacto
social que tiene que ver con nueva una
nueva constitución 130 congresistas que
a estas alturas de crispación no se
atreven a decir que quieren quedarse
hasta 2026 fecha en la que acaba el
mandato Pero ese es el mensaje que llega
a la ciudadanía que no entiende cómo no
alcanzar un acuerdo o sea que ellos
saben que es imposible quedarse tanto y
al mismo tiempo bloquean para desleatar
en el tiempo algo que es insostenible
que es digamos la cuadratura del círculo
en esta situación exactamente Es que
necesitan un tiempo no hay partidos
políticos como lo acaba de señalar
Valery y al mismo son grupos de
intereses lobbies organizados pero que
necesitan tiempo precisamente porque el
único momento en que se organizan
digamos de una manera institucional es
para las elecciones y por eso necesitan
un plazo de organización porque en el
estado actual de las cosas no va a haber
partidos que se puedan presentar
entonces hay esa parte y por la otra la
urgencia de organizarse ya desde ahora
mismo porque no podemos esperar que
sigan pereciendo personas que sigan
habiendo víctimas ya tenemos centenares
de víctimas desde diciembre del año
pasado entonces hay una urgencia y al
mismo tiempo esto es grupos políticos
necesitan un tiempo para organizarse
porque en temas económicos una campaña
electoral no se lleva en dos días se
tienen que solicitar muchos apoyos son
negociaciones son negociaciones también
para organizar los partidos políticos
para hacer la campaña Y eso es lo que
hace que estemos en unas cuadratura del
círculo creen que las elecciones serían
la solución O es un mal menor que debe
dar paso a otra otra cosa y Perú es una
democracia enferma ahora y hay un
problema de liderazgo en la en la
política hoy día tanto con Si vemos
Pedro Castillo que a keiko también
durante las últimas elecciones contamos
no con sus votos los suyos con su
partido no va más allá de la del del de
los votos que que podría tener con más
de 50 por ciento entonces creo que se
necesita un cambio tanto al dentro de
los partidos políticos y también ese
nuevo contrato social que es muy
importante con la sociedad peruana con
toda la sociedad peruana que existe pero
desde años eso no no es solo de ahora
pero esos diez últimos años tenemos solo
caso de corrupción tenemos caso también
en la selección de regionales donde cada
uno cada peruano va votando por su lista
independiente Entonces los partidos
políticos principales en Perú ya suenan
pero también tiene influencia en Lima en
las grandes ciudades mayormente pero en
los demás de Perú es no hay contrato con
los otros Son son grupos independientes
le hemos preguntado si
las elecciones serían una solución un
mal menor también al embajador de Perú
en Francia Rolando Ruiz rosas escuchen
lo que nos ha respondido en nuestro
programa escala en París la solución en
cauce constitucional es el adelanto de
estas elecciones frente a lo que es la
aspiración probablemente central de la
de la población que es una renovación
del la representación política actual
bueno sin duda en este momento la
atribución de la Reforma institucional
que conduzca el adelanto de elecciones
está en manos del Congreso de la
República y esperamos que esto pueda ser
resuelto en los plazos que la población
o la mayoría ha expresado interés en que
así sea confiamos que la clase política
en su conjunto tenga
la madurez suficiente para encontrar una
salida que atienda este este interés y
que desde el ejecutivo la presidenta ha
reiterado por lo mismo afirmándose como
un gobierno de transición la importancia
que se fije la reforma que se establezca
la reforma constitucional
valerie lizel guillón entonces La
pregunta es Qué posibilidades habría de
que entrara algo de renovación con unas
nuevas elecciones
o no hay
creo que en qué margen hay de que es que
no se puede hacer una sola reforma El
Perú en estos momentos necesita unas
reformas estructurales y globales no
solamente la solución no son las
elecciones la solución es organizar al
mismo tiempo juntas o movimientos
independientes colectivos de
participación ciudadana en general para
renovar esta clase política Para aportar
porque soluciones hay desde las
diferentes los diferentes regiones desde
diferentes bases hay soluciones hay
propuestas hay muchas propuestas hoy día
las redes sociales aún en las redes
sociales vemos como las la gente los
ciudadanos y ciudadanas Y a pie están
proponiendo tienen soluciones si se
trata ahora de hacer un gran pacto de
consenso global reconociendo a todas
esas vertientes políticas que se
organizan en las calles desde las calles
y no solamente desde el congreso de la
República con 130 personas
de algo a largo plazo pero en lo
inmediato en lo que se exige de adelanto
electoral también Tendría que haber una
solución parche digamos o algo la de la
organización es decir verdaderamente yo
creo que ahorita mismo la Constituyente
es la solución porque va a apaciguar de
alguna forma estas estas movilizaciones
va a permitir la expresión popular va a
permitir también de compensar el peso
extraordinario que tiene el parlamento
hoy día en el Perú porque los que
gobiernan esencialmente hoy es son los
miembros los congresistas que todos
tienen procesos de corrupción que todos
solamente velan por sus propios
intereses entonces hay que ampliar esa
base de de ejercicio político Por cierto
que más de 60 personas ya han muerto
expliquemos también porque esta
violencia es solo la parte visible de
una crisis que viene de lejos
no sé si hemos retratado lo suficiente
la violencia lo que es lima y lo que es
la que se ha producido en la periferia
porque zonas militarizadas como puno no
hay un de la violencia pero en Perú pero
tanto una violencia que de una parte de
la sociedad he visto como una una
violencia de estado y también del otro
lado como una violencia también frente a
unas crisis política frente a una crisis
económica que también se expende en el
tiempo durante sus últimos años y donde
no hay respuesta que decir que la
solución no se encuentra no no esperamos
o sea esperábamos el el 7 de diciembre
para encontrar solución había que
encontrar solución antes y lo que se
estaba jugando justamente con con Pedro
Castillo era la Constituyente y ahora
vemos que ese es el tema en Perú
Constituyente o solución con una
emergencia corta a corto plazo que son
las elecciones anticipadas vamos a hacer
una breve pausa en este punto pero a
vuelta vamos a intentar analizar los dos
males de fondo del Perú la corrupción Y
esa desconexión que existe entre lima y
la periferia va a ser a vuelta de pausa
sabe cómo identificarlas acompáñenos con
France 24 vea como distinguir entre
información y contenido falso en las
redes sociales desinformando una
herramienta para verificar y
contextualizar información
tras 24 es información certificada todos
los días en todas nuestras emisiones
[Música]
volvemos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando la crisis interminable que
vive Perú lo hacemos con balín roban
profesora de antropología social lisel
Quirós historiadora y guilón y guillón
ascari periodista independiente hay que
apuntar y analizar los males de fondo
para entender la crisis peruana que
están en el origen de todo la corrupción
y la desconexión entre lima y el resto
del país Cómo esperan los peruanos
arreglar estos mares de fondo porque
entendemos que la parte de la superficie
de esta crisis nunca va a quedar
resuelta si no se va al meollo de la
cuestión lisel absolutamente pienso que
hay que
estas reivindicaciones son antiguas en
realidad la violencia no nace en estos
últimos tiempos hay una reactivación más
bien de la violencia si pensamos en un
periodo relativamente reciente es desde
el conflicto armado interno o sea aquí
se está reactivando cosas que ya estaban
presentes desde los años 70 como mínimo
Entonces cómo
seleccionar este este tema es
equilibrando la hay un gran
desequilibrio una verdadera macrocefalia
del Perú El Perú cuenta una capital que
tiene todo los poderes concentra todos
los poderes diez millones de personas
que concentran prácticamente todos los
poderes en un país de 33 millones es
decir prácticamente un tercio de la
población y que es muy central y que es
centralista y que es cerrada y que
funciona como un espacio totalmente
clausurado y
un microcosmos absolutamente hay que
abrir hay que reconocerle a las otras
regiones y los procesos de
descentralización de regionalización
nunca funcionaron verdaderamente sino
como especies de paliativos para calmar
un poquito precisamente este tipo de
movilizaciones Entonces se trata de
darle a las regiones por ejemplo un
poder suficiente un espacio de
funcionamiento de escuchar otras
propuestas otras maneras de hacer
política porque hay hay propuestas Hay
muchas como estamos llegando a
soluciones es decir esa parte de
desconexión entre lima y la periferia
habría que abordarla cambiando la
estructura del país es decir pensando en
darle más poder a las regiones podría
venir de ahí sí y yo creo que también el
tema de los 200 años de la República
como promesa incumplida digamos sin
embargo no significa O sea la exclusión
de de esos sectores Rurales campesinos
provincianos no significa por lo tanto
este que no haya propuestas desde ahí y
ahora hemos visto durante estas
manifestaciones por ejemplo en las redes
sociales en tiktok que se están
manifestando también propuestas
políticas en quechua hay algo totalmente
inédito también donde se ve la gente
hablar en los idiomas autóctonos quechua
aymara reivindicando una no solamente
una una distinción sino este una un
pedido de inclusión ciudadana no Y eso
lo hacen desde sus idiomas en el espacio
público como nunca se ha hecho y es
cierto que el tema de la asamblea
Constituyente debe ser más inclusiva y
recoger todas esas propuestas
alternativas que vienen de la
movilización local porque no es porque
la gente de repente no sabe leer y
escribir que no tiene propuestas
políticas y un pensamiento político
complejo que aporta para el país es
decir estas poblaciones consideran que
su participación política El Perú de la
periferia está subvalorada Sí yo pienso
que hay una parte que considera que está
súper valorada pero si miramos también
si miramos también o sea unas elecciones
yo hablo siempre de las elecciones
regionales locales tienen tienen un voto
que cuenta pero eso también muestra la
desconexión entre las elecciones
generales
el funcionamiento claro y y los demás de
su sugirieron su localidad donde es
totalmente diferente entonces hay una
parte depende donde yo pienso que no hay
un Perú sino hay diferente Perú no
podemos hablar desde el Perú de cu como
el Perú de tacna como el Perú de
Arequipa no hay que mezclar todo porque
hay personas que piensa que esa que que
pensaba que estaba que que cuenta su
voto Y que ahora se dice yo yo yo no
creo que Mi voto está contando esa
desconfianza desconexión entre lima y la
periferia también ha actuado durante las
protestas les pregunto la protesta
social siempre ha estado mal vista desde
las élites de Lima se ha criminalizado
la protesta desde Lima lizel siempre
desde siempre se ha criminalizado y
desde la el conflicto armado interno el
apelativo de terruco de terrorista para
todas las personas que se movilizan
contra el gobierno contra los poderes en
que están en el poder encontrar a las
personas que están en el poder es algo
que es la estrategia para
deslegitimar ese tipo de movilizaciones
Entonces definitivamente y no se trata
de la misma manera a las movilizaciones
no se reprime de la misma manera esto
que haya la masacre en juliaca nunca se
no no hubiera podido pasar en un espacio
como Lima aún en la periferia de Lima O
sea hay verdaderamente una diferencia
Fiona a velocidades y niveles distintos
Entonces es decir que no se consideran a
los ciudadanos y es lo que lo que dicen
los peruanos y las peruanas Nosotros
somos una suerte de ciudadanos de
segunda categoría con relación a los
ciudadanos de Lima que ellos sí son los
limeños y Hoy día hay definitivamente en
esas movilizaciones claramente Una
dicotomía entre los limeños se dice
limeños en general no o sea es idea que
son los que tienen el poder y los demás
peruanos que no tienen los mismos
derechos en particular el de movilizarse
y expresar sus reclamos la
descentralización sería un proyecto a
largo plazo hay soluciones que van a lo
estructural pero también hay algo que
tiene que ser inmediato o soluciones que
tienen que venir sobre todo si la
represión y la violencia en las calles
crece habrá que buscar también
soluciones en el corto plazo
como el de evitar ese tipo de reacciones
políticas de represión de terrorismo de
Estado que nos recuerdan muchísimo los
el periodo los periodos precedentes es
cierto o sea el tema del problema ahí
vemos también este la las huellas del
conflicto armado interno en la gestión
de las manifestaciones y la acusación de
terrorista no solamente es grave porque
bueno es falsa pero sobre todo porque
entonces ve es una manera de ideologizar
también a las fuerzas armadas y a la
policía donde finalmente se deshumaniza
al otro se lo ve como el enemigo interno
Y entonces se justifica y banaliza la
muerte que se da y y hemos visto acá que
fueron con armas de guerra incluso Por
cierto me gustaría volver al origen de
todo esto vuelta el 7 de diciembre es el
punto de inicio de esta crisis castillo
y el autogolpe fallido castillo iba a
poder pasar la moción de censura como ya
lo hizo en otras ocasiones pero por qué
decides a esa jugada parece algo
desesperado falta de poder a eso Añadir
decisiones quizá erráticas mal rodeado
Con qué visión una estrategia mal hecha
Qué piensan dos meses después
Sigo pensando que fue una jugada
desesperada de llamamiento al pueblo en
la situación de que estaba Pedro
Castillo que se consideraba
completamente este encerrado y que lo
vio como la única alternativa muy mal
asesorado me parece en las
circunstancias de ese momento y pero que
fue una jugada la última jugada La
última carta que le quedaba política
comparto este punto de vista también
tiene pero tener una mala asesoría desde
el principio tiene también digamos
traición también al dentro de su partido
o sea dentro de su gobierno y también yo
pienso que el impacto bastante y era su
última carta decir si no la hago ahora
igual ahí me van a atacar del poder
castillos dio esperanzas a toda esa
gente que se había sentido en los
márgenes lejos de Lima pero no sé si
podemos decir que al tú alguna vez la
sensación de tener poder realmente
bueno poder tener poder real desde el
inicio desde que ganó las elecciones de
cualquier modo este la derecha y luego
el congreso le pusieron este
impedimentos para que pueda este
gobernar de hecho pero también este hay
una una ineptitud indudable también en
la gestión del gobierno porque ha habido
También muchas desilusiones en el
sentido de que por ejemplo la reforma
agraria que él había propuesto este
nunca hizo ningún proyecto este sobre
este tema de la Reforma que era un
pedido central también de la población
entonces
presidentes en cuatro años y que el
congreso peruano hace imposible ejercer
el poder es decir hay una cosa propia de
la derivada del propio castillo y hay
otra realidad también que responde a la
propia realidad de Perú y se mezclan
ambas claro y con una posición total y
yo creo que ningún presidente desde el
inicio de la República ha tenido tanta
presión y oposición sistemática de parte
del Congreso que no lo ha dejado
gobernar eso es cierto
que Castillo haya acabado como todos los
demás presidentes peruanos no vamos a
recordar la famosa lista es la gran
decepción para ese Perú olvidado que
tantas esperanzas puso en él sí
y lo dijeron lo dice esa frustración es
parte de lo que estamos viendo parte es
que forma parte En todo caso fue
la gota que rebasó el vaso no o sea es
decir se consideró como una gran
injusticia ya sea cierto no se ve así
desde la periferia desde las regiones se
ha condenado a este presidente porque
era un cholo que no venía del ámbito
general del establishment político no
Entonces se ve como una gran injusticia
y como una especie de Espejo donde se
ven reflejadas estas personas entonces
por eso el estallido social porque
podemos hablar de un verdadero estallido
social en Perú nace de ese acto que se
produjo hablamos antes de una de
posibles soluciones a más de un Perú más
descentralizado para para conectar mejor
al final al cabo el Lima con la
periferia Claro pero todos los mares del
país quizás sea la percepción y la
educación sobre corrupción porque por
mucho que se descentralice si la
corrupción es las entrañas lo que vamos
a hacer es descentralizar la corrupción
Cómo se ataja la cultura de la
corrupción en Perú guillón de una forma
el Perú está centralizado porque en Lima
encontramos todos los poderes pero
cuando vamos en Arequipa cuando vamos en
piura cuando vamos en tacna encontramos
gobernadores que tiene poderes pero esos
gobernadores se guardan a veces este
el tiempo de hacer reforma a veces de
tener o sea compromiso político y en
muchos casos no duran bastante tiempo no
tienen el tiempo de hacer este por
ejemplo encontramos obras paralizadas
encontramos también dificultad
económicas y personas que no que piden
democracia o sea participativa pero que
no están al dentro de un proceso
Entonces el proceso no nacional sino
tiene que ser regional y ahora hay una
desconexión al dentro de la región la
región es mismas de Perú que decir que
la corrupción le afecta también porque
sí hay la economía informal pero también
porque el gobernador también en la plata
no la distribuye también a todo todo lo
demás de la geón y de los distritos de
aldentro de la región claro
descentralizar no significa darle el
poder a los gobernadores de si no a las
comunidades más ampliamente
verdaderamente la solución para el Perú
es definitivamente que sean los
sea una un programa inclusivo en verdad
que no no se trata simplemente de
delegar El Poder a agentes del estado
que viven fuera de Lima sino más bien
que se integre a todos los niveles a
todas las escalas a los pueblos
originarios a todos los grupos
movilizados a todas las organizaciones
que tienen propuestas hoy día que están
proponiendo ya desde semanas soluciones
a esta crisis porque el cambio radical
ya es O sea ya no puedo el Perú no puede
dar marcha atrás esa sensación Yo creo
que la comparten los tres verdad que hay
algo en esta crisis que no se sabe dónde
está la salida Estamos de acuerdo Pero
sabemos tenemos una certeza Solo que ya
hay un punto de inflexión no sabemos un
proceso democratizador en curso me
acuerdo muchísimas gracias a los tres ha
sido un placer compartir este tiempo con
ustedes hemos aprendido muchísimo sobre
la crisis que vive Perú Desde hace dos
meses y a todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí en Primera Plana la próxima semana
Muchas gracias
[Música]